One of the first steps in annotation is to
identify all of the genes within a contig and
to determine the number of isoforms of each gene.
Remember that a gene is a DNA sequence that can
encode at least one functional RNA and protein
product. Each gene in the Drosophila genome has
a unique gene name. We will use the Genome
Browser to learn more about gene structure.
Go to the GEP UCSC Genome Browser gateway
page and select the D. melanogaster, July 2014
gene assembly. Enter "contig1" into the search term
box and click "submit." The default view shows the
entire length of contig1, which consists of 11 000
nucleotides. The FlyBase Genes track shows the D.
melanogaster genes on the "pack" display mode. With
this view, we can see the gene and isoform names to
the left of each feature. Many evidence tracks
have different display modes that you can use
to control how the UCSC genome browser renders
overlapping features. For example, let's change
the display mode for the FlyBase Genes track
to "dense" and click "refresh." The overlapping
features are now rendered in a single line. To
determine how many genes are in contig1, we will
count the number of features in the FlyBase Genes
track. Each feature consists of one or more boxes
which correspond to exons. The lines that
connect two adjacent boxes correspond to introns.
A gene is composed of a collection of boxes,
or exons, and lines that connect them together,
or introns. The gap between two adjacent genes is
known as the intergenic region. In this example,
contig1 contains three different genes and
each gene has multiple exons and introns.
Type contig1:1-5800 into the
search terms box and then press "enter" to zoom
into the region where the first gene is located
within contig1. Change the display mode for the
FlyBase Genes track to "full" and then click on the
"refresh" button. Now we can see that there are three
sets of exons and introns that correspond to the
three isoforms of the gene CG32165. An isoform is
an alternative form of a gene that results from
alternative splicing or the use of different sets
of transcribed exons in the processed mRNA. Each
isoform of a gene has a different mRNA sequence.
However, some isoforms may have the same amino
acid sequences because they use the same set
of coding exons. Let's look at the CG32165 gene
and examine the three isoforms in more detail.
The labels at the left side of the FlyBase Genes
track correspond to the names of the mRNA. In
Drosophila, the part of the name before the last
dash corresponds to the gene name, while the suffix
after the dash, such as RC, RB, or RA, corresponds
to the name of the isoform. For example, CG32165-RC
corresponds to the C isoform of CG32165. The arrows
within each intron denote the orientation of the
gene relative to the contig. Because the arrows
point from right to left, CG32165 is on the
complementary strand. This means that the first
transcribed exon is located at the right side
of the image. Isoform C has nine exons. Isoform
B also has nine exons, but note that exon one is
shorter. This isoform has a different transcription
start site. Isoform A only has eight exons,
the result of a mode of alternative splicing known
as intron retention. Let's zoom out to the entire
contig1 and look at the spd2 gene. Enter contig1 into the "enter position or search terms" text
box and then press "enter." We can see that there is
only one isoform of this gene, isoform A. Therefore
only one kind of mRNA is transcribed. Finally, let's
look at the tra gene. As indicated by the RA and RB
suffixes, there are two isoforms of the tra gene:
isoform A and isoform B. Each isoform has three
exons, but note that exon 2 is longer in isoform
B than in isoform A. This is an example of another
mode of alternative splicing that is caused by
the use of an alternative splice acceptor site.